how's it going everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder where
we talk all things marvel and
mcu and today we finally have an
official update from marvel studios
about
deadpool 3. deadpool of course was a fox
property that disney now
owns which means deadpool can now exist
in the marvel cinematic universe however
since this has happened there have been
a lot of crazy rumors flying around
rumors such as deadpool may not be rated
r
or he may not actually exist within the
mcu maybe he exists outside of the mcu
but is still under marvel studios there
have even been some rumors stating that
we might not get deadpool 3 for a very
long time but
today as i mentioned we got an update
from kevin feige and it sets the record
straight on
everything peter
are you catfished here or any powers you
want to tell us about any uh
no i i don't have one um i just
saw the ad no superpowers at all you're
in
yeah and we'll break down exactly what
kevin feige the president of marvel
studios said concerning
deadpool 3. and if you're new and you
love marvel be sure to subscribe so you
don't miss out on any of the latest mcu
content
so as it turns out ryan reynolds was not
trolling us when he mentioned in some
interviews and posted to his instagram
story that he was meeting with marvel
studios and
currently working on deadpool 3. this is
pretty much common knowledge at this
point because marvel studios announced
that they hired two writers along with
ryan reynolds
to write for deadpool 3. but while
speaking with collider kevin feige
confirmed that deadpool 3
is in fact in development right now and
he's extremely
excited for it this is what he had to
say in the interview it will be rated r
and we are working on a script right now
and ryan's overseeing a script right now
it will not be filming this year ryan is
a very busy
very successful actor we've got a number
of things we've already announced that
we have to now
make but it's exciting for it to have
begun
again a very different type of character
in the mcu
and ryan is a force of nature which is
just awesome to see him
bring that character to life this is
straight from the mouth of marvel
studios president kevin feige and he
just
revealed five major things about the
upcoming deadpool project so let's break
down
those five things and the first thing is
that kevin feige has confirmed that
deadpool 3
will be rated r this is something that
some fans
really weren't sure about since marvel
studios is owned by
disney and they're not too fond of rated
r content we weren't really
sure if they were going to keep deadpool
or allow deadpool to remain
rated r but disney has announced that
they are going to be having an
adult content section on disney plus
this will be a feature that you can
enable in the settings of disney plus
that allows you to see rated r content
now of course deadpool is going to be a
feature film
once theaters get fully back at it but
the point is disney doesn't seem to have
a problem with doing a rated r
film and that's good because it's hard
to imagine deadpool not being rated r
the second important thing mentioned is
that they are working on a script right
now and
ryan reynolds is working on a script
right now while filming deadpool 2
and after deadpool 2 ryan reynolds made
it very clear that he wanted to be in
charge of deadpool
and i think everybody knows that that
character is made by ryan reynolds
himself
he essentially is deadpool and he very
publicly mentioned that he wanted
control of the character
and of the next film but after deadpool
2 came out disney and marvel studios got
the rights back to all of their
characters
deadpool being one of those characters
and fans started to wonder if ryan
reynolds was going to get the control
over deadpool that he wanted since he's
now
at disney and marvel studios and marvel
studios and
kevin feige specifically are a
powerhouse they are the big dogs the
people responsible for
avengers in-game the highest grossing
film of all time
but it looks like ryan is going to be
given the creativity freedom that he's
wanted for a long time now
of course kevin feige is going to have
to approve and we'll have overall say of
what ryan reynolds writes but it is nice
to know that they are letting him
write the script and kevin feige does
call ryan reynolds a force
of nature third important thing that
kevin feige mentions here is that it
will not be filming
this year this doesn't come as too big
of a surprise at disney's investor day
they announced a
ton of new projects and as kevin feige
already mentioned
in this interview we've got a number of
things we've already announced that we
now have to make
they have a lot of stuff on their plate
and as he mentioned in this interview
ryan is a very busy very successful
actor
so it's not going to be filming this
year however the fourth
important thing that this does tell us
is a rough estimate on when to expect
the deadpool 3 release date
since they are working on the script
right now they have the writing team
attached to it
kevin feige said in this interview it
has begun
meaning production and since he said
it's not filming this year but didn't
say
that it wouldn't be filming for a couple
of years or a few years
and given marvel's filming schedule that
we already know
this means it's going to film next year
2022
which means that we are probably getting
deadpool 3 and
20 23. only two years away
and that's a lot sooner than i think a
lot of people expected this could
actually be at the end of phase four
since kevin feige recently
in the same interview said that he
cannot say when phase 4
ends meaning that everything they've
revealed for phase 4
isn't everything and that they actually
have more to reveal and deadpool 3
is probably going to be one of those
projects that is going to come at the
end of phase four
if not the very beginning of phase five
and last but not least
the fifth major reveal is that deadpool
is not going to change if anything he is
going to be better
kevin feige mentions that ryan reynolds
is going to be writing the script along
with some other writers
but at the end of his statement he says
again a very different type of character
in the mcu
and ryan is a force of nature which is
just awesome to see him bring that
character to life
this means that kevin feige in marvel
studios is not going to interfere with
how
deadpool is there's no toning him down
since it's going to be rated r
it's going to be the exact same deadpool
that we've known in deadpool 1
and deadpool 2. and like i said if
anything he's going to be better than
before because ryan reynolds is going to
tackle the script
for deadpool 3. remember he wanted to
tackle deadpool 3 all by himself because
ryan reynolds basically is deadpool and
that's not going to change now
kevin feige is calling him a force of
nature and says it's
awesome to see him be the character so
we're probably going to get a better
deadpool than
ever and now we get to see him interact
with the heroes that we know
and love which is going to be fantastic
ryan reynolds has even taken to
instagram and twitter already
talking about deadpool 3. on twitter ign
posted about the news stating deadpool 3
will join the mcu as
an r-rated movie according to marvel
studios president kevin feige
and in true ryan reynolds fashion he
replied with full disclosure
i showed them spider-man 1 and 2 and
told them it was deadpool1n2
deadpool 3. then on instagram replying
to the same article he said
first order of business find the guy who
killed bambi's mom
hashtag deadpool3 so production on
deadpool 3
has begun it's going to be a kevin feige
and ryan reynolds film which sounds
absolutely fantastic the script is being
worked on right now
deadpool is going to exist in the marvel
cinematic universe and it's going to be
rated r pretty much everything that
everybody has wanted for deadpool 3
is happening so if you would like to
stay up to date on future
deadpool 3 related news be sure to
subscribe so you don't miss out on
any of the latest videos be sure to like
the video and
down below in the comments let me know
what you would like deadpool 3 to be
who would you like to be in deadpool
including heroes and villains
and would you like it to be in present
time or something like lion king
1.5 where deadpool is kind of in the
background of all the events of avengers
end game
let me know in the comments down below
for live updates you can follow me on
instagram and twitter and as always
thank you all so much for watching
woof